without this artificial price that we
put on cocaine I wouldn't be selling
cocaine hi I'm Zack Weiss Miller for
Reason TV
we're here with freeway Rick Ross today
he was the notorious drug dealer from
the 1980s who is widely credited with
introducing crack cocaine on a mass
scale in Los Angeles and eventually
nationwide a federal judge sentenced
Ross to life in prison for purchasing
more than a hundred kilograms of cocaine
from a federal agent but an appeals
court found that this amounted to over
sentencing and Ross walked free in 2009
his latest autobiography tells the story
of his rise to and fall from power he'll
be featured in an upcoming documentary
freeway crack in the system about his
life and he's portrayed by Michael K
Williams in the new movie kill the
messenger about the late journalist Gary
Webb freeway Rick Ross thank you very
much for joining us thank you for having
me
you are inextricably linked with Los
Angeles I mean your nickname comes from
the 110 freeway could you just describe
Los Angeles at that time and and what
the dividing line that the freeway
represented you know when you went east
of the 110 freeway it turned black and
when you went west it was all white it
was definitely segregated in the 110
freeway was that line I think it's fair
to say you you grew up in the heart of
Crips territory but you went to high
school at Dorsey high which is actually
only a few miles from where we are right
now and you got into Dorsey through an
unusual path you started playing tennis
outside of the school and the tennis
coach saw you and recruited you to come
to the school was that your ambition at
the time when it became apparent to me
that I wasn't going to be big enough to
play basketball the football then I was
looking for another way to to get myself
out to get oh you went through school
without ever learning to actually read
that is where we see this transition
where you're about to go off and pursue
a tennis scholarship in college but the
coach tells you we can't accept someone
who is unable to read absolutely and
then is that the moment where you
started turning to drug dealing where
you say well I started to start to slide
back into south-central a and you know
not going over to a door C as much as I
used to and you know starting to hang
out with guys in the community guys that
I went to elementary and junior high
school wit and next thing I'm at the
street braces and then I want a a street
car and it just kept going on and on and
on to the next thing I know you know I'm
getting introduced to cocaine what was
it about cocaine that made it such an
attractive product to sell right away
profit vitamins about pcp at that time I
learned about angel dust but the money
in those weren't is attractive and those
two drugs were more of a harsher drugs
so moving from powder cocaine to crack
cocaine was a big deal in terms of
profitability for your business could
you just describe what exactly is the
difference when I first started selling
I was selling powder and the guys would
be snorting snorting and a nose would
start to lead and would mess up denim
brings well with crack that never
happened you can't smoke enough crack
you can OD on crack was windup going to
happen is that your money's going around
in the book you describe the scene along
81st Street it's this kind of open
market Bazaar and there's no police
interference talk about that that scene
a little bit and how it was even
possible that that would exist well for
a long time the police never never came
over drugs is considered a victimless
crime
so it's kind of like a crime where
nobody's going to come in and testify
unless the police get involved people
were randomly walking up to cars people
was coming down the sidewalk at any
given day that could be 10 to 15 guys
out selling PCP sticks so what I did is
I saw that they had that type of
openness I just said you know all I got
to do is bring my cocaine here and fit
right into him and eventually the
cocaine took over in the PCP guys left
and went away what was it about you and
your style that made you kind of rise to
the top and
I saved my money I didn't blow my money
I didn't take my money and go out and
buy jeans and hats and tennis shoes and
go change what I did is I took my money
and I wouldn't bought more drugs did you
ever consider moving out of the drug
business and aboveboard I didn't I did I
wanted to a chain of hotels I also did
apartment buildings houses when I was
building houses I did real good at it
really yeah I made about four hundred
thousand dollars a year but where I
messed up at with all of my other
businesses is that I never stopped
selling drugs I'm sure that paled in
comparison to the amount of money you
were making off the drugs you did one of
the more controversial claims involves
Oscar Danilo Blandon a supplier who
turned out to be a federal agent and was
the person who ultimately led to your
downfall
you were a source for the journalist
Gary Webb who claimed that Landon was
funneling cocaine money to the Contras
either with the help of the CIA or with
the kind of like turn-the-other-cheek
attitude Co CIA do you stand by Webb's
reporting since Gary's past you know the
CIA has coming out and admitted that
they were working with known drug
traffickers so now it's no longer this
myth or this perception that it may have
happened or may not have happened and
absolutely happened the government
admitted it they put it in their own
report sometimes it spins off into
theories like oh the government
purposely created the crack epidemic in
LA you wouldn't go that far with you it
doesn't matter if they purposely planned
on doing that well wind up happening is
it flooded the ghettos of America
600,000 black men in prison right now
for nonviolent crimes our prison
industry has boomed so that happened you
know why did it happen was it personally
targeted we may never know out of an
orphan and those guys were given a part
before they ever went to trial so the
evidence never came out how's the drug
war over it's past 40 years which is
very much aligned with your life been a
success or a failure you know people ask
me Oh will you send should drugs be
legal
I don't know what I do know is that the
drug border we're fighting right now is
a total failure there's more drugs on
the street of American and ever before
you know I think it's time to take all
these old people out of here who's been
sitting back making money off the prison
industry not caring if it's going to in
a drug war
you made millions of dollars selling
drugs how do you think your life would
have been different if there had not
been a war on drugs at that time well
without this artificial price that we
put on cocaine I wouldn't have been
selling cocaine you give a kid the
opportunity to make a thousand dollars a
week rather than being broke no lesson
going to McDonald's and working for at
that time 350 an hour you know which one
would he choose we've talked about the
war on drugs and the victimless nature
of drug crimes the other side would say
it's not so victimless that it's been
called the crack epidemic in the past
and it's ruined thousands of lives
ravaged communities do you have any
personal regrets about getting into this
business definitely have some regrets
you know I regret ever getting involved
but then on the other hand people
volunteer to get high you know nobody's
putting a gun up to anybody's head
saying oh you got a go for you and get
high and I believe that everybody that's
involved is just as responsible there's
an argument that okay addiction it's
it's a sickness and you're preying on
that sickness they don't really have a
choice in the traditional sense do you
not you don't buy that you do get drawn
in and it's tough to quit yeah but it's
also tough for the dealer to quit
because he gets drawn into to the money
he gets just his hook and for him it's
worse for him because nobody tells him
to quit see his whole family and his
whole community encourages them to keep
going that you're doing good but with
the user people were telling you is if
well you look bad with a dealer they
don't say well you look good I like that
car I like those jeans and shoes I want
stay cause you have some regrets
but the money you made and what you've
done is allowing you to kind of take a
different path now and give back
you went from going through the entire
school system not being able to read and
now you're making book recommendations
it's an important part of the story
really because you learn to read and
were able to get yourself out of a life
sentence can you just describe how that
all well will rival my celly convinced
me that I could we
he made me my ABCs on some cue cards and
he taught me how to sound my words out I
went from there to reading the newspaper
to eventually reading law books and then
I found the issue that got me sitting
here with you today and the issue that
you discovered was the fact that you had
been over sentenced right yeah yeah they
they charged me with the three strike
law because I had been taken from state
to state in charge but they ran on my
time concurrent and the fact that I had
never gotten out of prison
you came here wearing a shirt saying the
real rick ross is not a rapper so i'm
assuming there's a message you're trying
to get across would you like to share
that yeah yeah that's a guy who uses my
name and uh may have been into a little
bit of a battle hoping my name and uh
this is my way of taking a shot at on
doing all right so take note rick ross
thank you very much thank you again for
recent TV I'm Zack Weiss Muller
you